on the opioid epidemic in the u.s. he
demonstrated how Johnson & Johnson took
data out of context with respect to
their branded opioids minimized safety
issues related to those opioids omitted
material information related to the
safety of their opioids and made
comparative efficiency claims about
their opioids without substantial
evidence and possibly the most
significant and heart-rending part of
our trial was when we gave the world a
glimpse of what victims of the epidemic
look like Christi whose and John
McGregor nearly lost everything to their
addictions and they were the lucky ones
they lived to tell their stories because
in our state there are countless
families like the family of oh you
football star Austin box
his parents Craig and Gayle go to bed
every night and wake up every morning to
the insufferable reality of knowing they
will never see their beautiful son
Austin again and because Johnson and
Johnson targeted pregnant women in our
state we also heard from the executive
director of peppers Ranch Tonya
Ratcliffe who discussed what it's like
caring for babies born with an addiction
to opioids we saw an actual video of a
newborn shaking uncontrollably as it
suffered the effects of neonatal
abstinence syndrome from the minute
these babies draw their first breath
their lives are negatively impacted and
perhaps will never be the same
regrettably we can't change the past we
can never bring back those who lost
their lives because Johnson & Johnson
executives made the calculated and
cold-blooded decision that they were
going to produce a mutant strain of
poppy corner of the market and supply
massive amounts of the active
ingredients for other companies
to manufacture opioids around the nation
and in Oklahoma the family members who
still struggle with the loss of a loved
one will remain the victims devastated
devastated by this corporate greed
forever I know personally and have met
with and spoken to families of those
whose loved ones have been erased by an
opioid overdose words will never be
enough to take their pain away I do
however hope that today judge Bachmann's
decision will provide some solace to the
thousands of families who have
tragically lost a loved one due to an
opioid overdose and today should also
inspire a sense of optimism to those
struggling with an opioid addiction
because we are committed to getting you
the help you need to reclaim your life
and your future it has taken over two
years for us to get here there have no
doubt been some bumps along the way we
suffered through attacks and obstacles
moments of trepidation and worry but
also moments of hope and today great
triumphs through it all this incredible
team has stuck together and I want to
say it took tremendous courage from this
team of highly skilled attorneys these
are attorneys who've suffered greatly
not just during this case being away
from their families and not taking on
other work but many on this team have
lost loved ones to addiction at the
hands of these deadly drugs they know
firsthand the anguish of burying a
family member who they first had to
watch spiraling to despair Judge Mike
Burrage his law partner Reggie Whitten
and everyone at Wittenberg Brad
Beckworth and his team at Nix Patterson
and also from my office first assistant
Don cash general counsel Abbie dill
savor the many assistant AG's paralegals
and support staff put in just as much
time as an effort as everybody who was
in court these last seven weeks
we persevered we did so because we knew
that in the end we were going to be on
the right side of history we will look
back on the start period and know that
we stood up for Oklahomans to take on
Goliath it has not been easy but it has
been well worth it finally just as we've
said several times at different stages
of this case when Johnson and Johnson
pulled out all stops to try to derail
install the case we appreciate Judge
Bachmann's wisdom and openness he
clearly saw through all the company's
desperate acts to delay justice for
Oklahomans in closing what we showed
during our seven week trial and what
judge Bachmann confirmed today is what
we know now for certain Johnson and
Johnson was the kingpin behind the
nation's ongoing opioid crisis and I
have a message for the CEO of Johnson &
Johnson on Monday of last week the
Business Roundtable a group that
represents CEOs of big corporations
declared that it had changed its mind
about the purpose of corporations that
purpose is no longer to maximize profits
for shareholders but to benefit other
stakeholders as well including employees
customers and citizens Johnson & Johnson
is a member of the Business Roundtable
and I'm asking the CEO of Johnson &
Johnson Alex Gorsky put his money where
his mouth is and get out his checkbook
happy to answer any questions
question over here and then here well
Robert Browning once said a man's reach
should exceed his grasp or what's a
heaven for so we took the position that
given all the scientific review all the
expert consultation that we did with
with folks like Terry and her team with
the diction scientists in the state and
around the country that given the
potential for folks to relapse and given
the extent of the epidemic dealing with
it comprehensively was something that we
felt was the most responsible way to
address this so we gave the judge a
20-year 20-year plan a 30-year plan
again that was designed to ensure that
we were dealing with everything that
this defendant caused so what we have is
cumulative ly from other from the other
defendants in this case we've been able
to put together almost a billion dollars
to help people in the state deal with
the consequences of their actions and
we're very proud to be where we are
today the judge's order as we've
reviewed it is very clear with respect
to the actions of the defendant and its
culpability with regard to the epidemic
in the state question over here then
here question over here
two million the judge said one year do
you go back to the judge and ask for
more or to the legislature as the judge
said this stamp should be addressed by
the legislature well it's a 40-plus page
opinion we have speed readers on our
team but they don't read that fast so
we're gonna spend some time looking at
the opinion
we've also we've I've already started
meetings with the leadership of the
legislature and the governor so there's
going to be a united front with regard
to how we proceed with this it's it's
it's going to be an important step
forward in dealing with the epidemic you
know certainly we would have liked to
walk out of here with seventeen point
five billion dollars seventeen billion
dollars in change but realistically
we've been able again to put together
almost a billion dollars to help
Oklahoma work its way through question
here and then right there there's no
question about it and the record that's
now available to my colleagues in other
states is certainly something that's
going to assist this process around the
country there is no question in my mind
that we had to bring this case that it
had to be tried that these facts had to
see sunlight that's been accomplished
here and at the end of the day you can't
sit in a corporate suite somewhere for
the last twenty years and over supply
the country ten times more of this drug
was coming in and then you had
concomitantly 15 times more people dying
from opioid overdoses so there's no
question in my mind that these companies
knew what was going on at the highest
level they just couldn't quit making
money from it and that's why they're
responsible
so one of the things that's that's
important about the job that I have and
the job that these gentlemen have
assisted me in in doing the last seven
weeks is I've got to know the vollis to
the people the state the four million
people of this state and they all have
they all have families and friends they
all have things that are important to
them and if you ever get to the point as
I believe happened in these corporate
Suites where you're looking at people as
data points or you're looking at all
this death and destruction as a cost of
doing business that you don't have to
incur if you ever get to that point you
really ought to be ashamed of yourself
and again that's why I'm asking the CEO
of Johnson & Johnson to step up put his
money where his mouth is get this
judgment paid so that we can start
helping Oklahomans the boxes were
continuing inspiration to us and for
those of you who've got young people
who've gotten injured and they've been
given painkillers you're lucky because
you never know you might be in that one
out of four one out of five universe of
people who's got a vulnerability to
addiction you don't know it it's part of
your physiology and that's another big
part of this they didn't know there's
never been any authoritative studies
that determine the extent to which you
can become addicted to a prescription
opioid but they didn't care so
specifically Austin and Gayle have been
inspirations to us and every time I
think about Austin and I know a lot of
us feel that way you know we think about
our children
Reggie whatever if somebody people don't
realize watching on the national stage
that you have such a what does this day
mean for you and your loved ones I saw
your wife in the courtroom a lot of
members of your family tell us a little
bit about what this day means for you
now come on everybody it's a pretty hard
question to answer
I'll try I feel like my boys looking
down that's pretty pretty tough deal but
I think my son and Austin are
celebrating today we got to get help
that these other kids stopped very
grateful for the court for what he did
and depends on what these other
customers do now am i optimistic I think
I think they'll appeal this thing and
fight till hell freezes over but my boy
and Austin are fighters and we are -
it's hard because you love your kids you
know you're you're looking at the worst
thing I ever did in their whole life
that's all people just goodbye
Austin was a good boy my stomach they
got sick and what you know what I know
what caused it now and I plan on
fighting and in some form or fashion the
rest of my life but I'm still here and
I'm gonna keep fighting thank you
well I've said all along that on the
back end of this there's going to have
to be implementing legislation so next
steps are something that we're gonna
have to work through again with the
state's leaders but going forward the
judge left open
I guess the strong possibility and in
fact I think he forecasted that they're
going to be subsequent orders that will
clarify and implement the opinion so
those are all things that we're gonna
have to work through over the coming
days and weeks somebody else Castile no
question about it
in our judgment the best way to proceed
the complexity of the other claims in
our case we evaluated carefully we also
again we're looking towards what do we
need to do to address not only the
president but the future and so as we
looked at as we looked at public
nuisance law it was clear to us that
that was the best way to maximize any
kind of a judgment that we were able to
obtain in court here and so no looking
back we made the right decision I'm
confident Chris Thanks
[Music]
so my understanding where we are in the
contract is if we're able to finalize
this judgment get it collected of course
kita writes a check
there'll be most of this is going to be
subject to a single-digit retainer on
the part of the of the team there's a
small part of that that will be I think
just over ten percent other questions
over here everything's on the table
other questions
back here and over here Brad you want
talk about that sure this little groups
been underestimated our whole lives and
what Lodi all don't know is the team
behind you that helps support us has
truthfully for two years lived in an
office many people lived on mattresses
and judge Birds his office including
himself and we've all had personal
losses nothing like Reggie's but rulings
and a lot of difficulty along the way at
every turn J&J has been a company of
what I can only call institutional
arrogance they have called our claims
baseless they have laughed at
commissioner white more than once who if
you guys don't know is the
longest-serving Commissioner of mental
health in this entire country and
everyone out there should look at what
she did in her career before this case
and also in the abatement plan that she
and our team put together because it is
a map of what needs to happen in this
country they've underestimated general
hunter you guys probably know that they
have run everything they could at him
and even during this trial when we had
proven that these drugs
are in their own experts words up to 25
percent addictive and that 1 in 15
people will turn to heroin after
prescription drug use even after their
own corporate representatives set that
they have never done the testing to tell
you whether when your child is
prescribed one of their drugs they will
become an addict and die they said in
that chair and that witness stand and
said they had zero responsibility for
this crisis and today for the first time
in Oklahoma history and in this entire
country due to the leadership of this
man and the help of this woman we know
that the root of this entire crisis
began in Tasmania and New Jersey with
Johnson & Johnson and they can't laugh
anymore they can't call this case
baseless anymore and they had a hundred
lawyers working against a team of 13 and
the attorney general staff who has a lot
of jobs and we beat them at every turn
including today so I don't know why if
that answers your question but these two
guys and us have never backed down Randi
Alice down here Bob and then maybe just
one more after that so if you look at
this being a one-year judgment with a
billion dollars just taking the 572
million by itself for one year knowing
that it's one year 20 years right we're
talking 11 billion dollars 30 years as
we think it will take to abate the
crisis we're talking 15 billion dollars
I think we are right on track to start
the necessary treatment prevention
education both public education and
medical education programs obviously I'm
not an attorney and have not read the
order that just was released that was
over 40 pages but I'm really hopeful
this is the big giant first step in year
one that we are going to be the first
state in the nation to abate this crisis
one more question last chance okay one
more well I think this exercise is a
model and again I I can't say enough
about the team that we deployed here
the lawyers that work for these
gentlemen I'm getting there and and what
I would say in answer to your question
is if you put a team together and you're
able to steel yourself against all the
opposition all the criticism that you're
gonna get for taking on companies like
this at the end of day it's about talent
and resolve and courage and this team
had the talent and resolve and courage
to take this case to trial and win and
so that's the message to other states we
did in Oklahoma and you can do it
elsewhere okay thank y'all very much